Yeah,
well I was also really interested at the time,
man,
now in the biological basis of behavior.
Right.
And so,
and,
and in the,
uh,
in the relationship between fundamental motivational systems and thought because
obviously our thought is grounded in fundamental motivational systems and your
work on disgust with maybe you can tell the viewers a little bit about,
was really interesting to me because it was an emotional system that hadn't been
studied much.
I mean,
you were really one of the pioneers in the,
in the psychological study of disgust.
Well,
the way to explain it is that Paul Rosin,
my advisor at Penn is the pioneer in this study of disgust.
And he'd studied it as a food related emotion and he'd written a bit about it
being a moral emotion.
And I was a graduate student at Penn and I was interested in morality and I was
reading the Bible and I was reading,
um,
uh,
anthropological accounts of different countries and different cultures.
And at the time morality was all about reasoning about harm,
rights and justice.
So Lawrence Kohlberg was the leading figure in the field.
And because I was looking at morality across cultures,
uh,
and when you look across cultures,
it's not just about fairness and Harmon rights,
it's about menstruation and food taboos and skin lesions.
And it's very physical.
And I was,
you know,
why?
Why does so many societies,
why is it like the normal default way of being is to somehow bring the body into
morality?
Why is that?
And so I just happened to be at Penn where the world's expert in disgust was and
I went to talk to them and that started one of the best collaborations of my
life.
And what it led to is,
is a broadening of the,
of the moral domain.
Basically there's a sort of a western secular approach that you see in western
philosophers.
I have,
their morality is about harm and utilitarianism and let's minimize harm or it's
about rights and principles,
you know,
manual con and a much better way psychologically I think about morality is
virtue ethics.
It's just a lot of stuff.
It's just we have just a lot of stuff that we judge on.
And this led me eventually to realize that people on the left and people on the
right care about different stuff.
Everybody cares about harm and fairness,
but the stuff about keeping your boundaries around the group,
it'll to wall,
protect the group,
hold the group together,
hate traders.
Um,
you know,
everybody can do that.
But right.
We morality built on these additional additional foundations of these additional
emotions and foundations.
Um,
so that work on discussed that I was just beginning to talk about them when we
first met in 1994 led eventually to what we now call moral foundations theory
and with might with that five or six colleagues that if you go to your
morals.org,
uh,
you can take our test,
you can learn all about it.
Um,
but it led to the perspective that ultimately was,
I think the right perspective as the cultural war was heating up and as left and
right,
we're essentially becoming like different countries,
different cultures.